nos preguntan qué círculos están
divididos en cuartos en cuatro partes
iguales también nos dicen elige todas
las opciones correctas veamos esta
primera opción tengo este círculo
dividido en 1 2 3 4 partes pero no son
cuartos porque no son partes iguales
esta parte de aquí como de media luna es
diferente a esta parte de aquí así que
esta no aplica esta otra tengo el
círculo dividido en 1 2 3 4 partes y
cada una de ellas son iguales este si es
y este otro pues también tenemos
dividido el círculo en 1 2 3 4 y cada
una de estas partes son partes iguales
también aplica la última opción igual
tenemos 1 2 3 4 partes y cada una de
estas partes son iguales esto también
aplica vamos a comprobar las respuestas
es correcta realizamos otro ejercicio
que círculos están divididos en tercios
tercios en tres partes iguales
elige todas las opciones correctas aquí
tenemos la primera opción que está
dividido en 123 partes este círculo y
cada una de estas partes son iguales
esta aplica aquí tenemos el círculo
también dividido en tres partes pero no
son tercios no son partes iguales esta
parte de aquí no es igual a esta parte
de acá esta no aplica lo mismo para esta
opción está dividido en tres pero no son
tres partes iguales y la última opción
tenemos el círculo dividido en uno dos
tres cuatro partes que son iguales pero
no son tercios ésta tampoco aplica
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta es
correcta hagamos un problema más que
rectángulos están divididos en mitades
elige todas las opciones correctas
recordamos que mitades son dos partes
iguales dividir un objeto a la mitad es
dividir
en dos partes iguales esta opción
tenemos aquí el rectángulo dividido aquí
con esta diagonal y son dos partes
iguales
esta opción se aplica aquí tengo el
rectángulo dividido por esta diagonal
esta línea y me lo está dividiendo en
dos partes iguales está en mitades está
se aplica esta otra opción tengo el
rectángulo dividido en 1234 partes pero
son cuartos no mitades no me aplica esta
opción tiene el rectángulo dividido en
dos partes pero no son iguales este es
mucho más grande que esta no son mitades
tampoco aplica finalmente esta opción
aquí si tengo el rectángulo dividido en
dos partes y son dos partes iguales
también la elijo comprobamos la
respuesta
es correcta hagamos un último problema
eso es muy parecida a la anterior que
rectángulos están divididos en mitades
elige todas las opciones correctas
aquí tenemos como en el ejemplo anterior
al rectángulo dividido en dos partes
iguales este triángulo de aquí es igual
a este de acá esta opción aplica aquí
tengo a este rectángulo también dividido
en dos partes y son dos partes iguales
son mitades también la elijo y esta
tercera opción tengo el mismo rectángulo
pero ahora dividido verticalmente y me
lo divide en dos partes iguales esta
también aplica esta tiene el rectángulo
dividido en 123 partes son tercios no
mitades así que ésta no la selecciona
compruebo respuesta y es correcta